Jaakko from 115 podcast number 115 as a
leader how best to respond to someone
like corporal Meyer when he brings up
good questions in in a brief that need
to be addressed without derailing the
brief and calling your competence /
authority into question okay so what
he's talking about is on podcast 115
with Dakota Meyer which if you haven't
listened to it and listened to it
it's long and it's very I don't know
it's it's awesome anyways in part of
that podcast Dakota is getting told how
they're gonna conduct this operation and
Dakota raises some point and says what
about this what about that and what
about this other thing and they don't
listen to him and so the question here
is if you're in charge you're the leader
and you get someone that brings up these
questions during a brief during a plan
that you need to be that need to be
addressed how do you do it how do you
handle that properly okay well first of
all and the most important part of this
is if you involve your team in the
planning itself you won't have these
questions come up during the brief
they'll come up during the planning
mm-hmm so that's that's the ultimate and
best way to solve this problem you don't
plan in a vacuum as the leader and then
present the plan to the troops and
expect that you're gonna have the
perfect plan you did use only your brain
working on it what about everyone else's
brain what about everyone else's
perspective they have experience and
they have knowledge that you don't have
so if you involve them in the planning
then they ask you those questions early
and you figure out what the right
answers to those questions are so that's
how you solve the problem right there
now if it happens that for whatever
reason you're you didn't have the
opportunity to do that or you didn't do
it well enough or whatever the case may
be and now you start getting questions
on your plan while you're briefing well
first of all if they ask you questions
that you don't have answers to then that
then that could indicate that you're
wrong actually you could actually be
wrong and not a lot of leaders like to
feel that way but you should actually be
happy that someone on your team is
pointing out something that is going to
make
to plan better as a whole mmm so there's
that and and it's really easy if someone
if you're in a brief and someone brings
up a point that you didn't think of and
it makes sense well then you can
implement that into the plan okay
so that now you might think that it
hurts your authority mmm right to say
hey that's a good point echo I didn't
think of that let's implement you might
think or feel like that's gonna make you
look bad but if the opposite is actually
true if I go no echo hey the plans
already completed you weren't there for
the planning so just be quiet that's the
guy that no one respects that's the guy
that's not looking good as a leader and
that's the person that's losing
authority so you don't look weak if you
listen to members of the team whether
they're junior or senior it also shows
that you're incompetent if you because
because you missed the party obviously
the question is pertinent that they
asked or I should say if the question is
pertinent and it is a good point then it
shows that you missed an important angle
of the plan so open your mind open your
put your ego and check and incorporate
it in there now this can also happen if
there's something that you know that
you're right on but something that you
know that you're right on if there's
something like that and you end this
below maybe you get one particular
individual that keeps pushing back and
keeps pushing back and you might have to
in those cases say you know what hey
echo let me let me talk to you after
this brief is over and I'll explain to
you exactly while we're doing it this
way mm-hmm so that way doesn't derail
the brief because it might take a longer
explanation than you want to you know
for instance the typical seal briefing
was we tried to keep it 50 minutes to an
hour so if you got if you got to spend
eight minutes pulling up a different map
and explaining some detail of the
terrain to this guy that has a protest
to what you're saying you might say hey
listen we get done with this brief I'll
pull you aside let me show you the let
me show you the terrain map and you can
see exactly why we're using this
insertion route or whatever the case may
be
so you can do that if you have to and
even then they might end up having a
point that you didn't see and then you
can say okay well I didn't see that and
now we have to give everyone a quick
on a rebreathing on some change in the
plan but again none of this will happen
if you bring your subordinates in and
you let them do first of all let them do
the planning that's ideal let them come
up with Lana let ecco come up with the
plan I'm not coming up the plan you go
come up the plan I'm gonna check with
you and make sure that the plan is going
in the right direction make sure it's
not totally off track and then you'll
incorporate all these things and I'll
have a better view of the plan I can
stand back and be the tactical genius as
we talk about the book extreme ownership
like that's how you do it
hmm so that's the answer
well at least is an answer yeah maybe
other people have other answers seems to
make sense to me
yeah that's that hard it's hard right
when you when you it's one of those
things you always got to be conscious of
when you have a plan or whatever and
someone for lack of a better term pokes
holes in it mm-hmm like hey what about
this what about this and then you have
that those two elements that you got to
keep in mind where it's like the fact
that it's your plan and then the plan
you know the effectiveness I mean your
emotional attachment to the plan yeah
you got to keep the emotional attachment
to the plan in Jack versus the actual
effectiveness of the plan yeah and
people have a hard time doing that and
what's cool what's cool is once you
break away from that mindset then it's
really easier just to be and and
everyone just kind of knows well yeah
chuckles you know he's got an open mind
he'll listen to you yeah as opposed to
someone that has a closed mind never
goes out you can't you can't give me
anything by this guy oh geez he's got to
keep he doesn't even help to point
things out because he won't listen and
then guess what you're using one brain
versus 20 brains you know and more
important than the brainpower the
perspective the different perspectives
is the guys on the ground or the guys
with the technical knowledge and the
tactical knowledge they're gonna know
things that you don't know that's the
way it is
mmm you can't know everything that they
know mm-hmm and so if you shut down all
those different perspectives you're
looking at something from one angle you
know and do you see the whole complete
picture when you only look at something
from one angle no you don't know sir use
those other perspectives you know check
self-correcting machine mmm yes getting
let go of the
you go the taking a personal well
personally when I was in the SEAL Teams
I called it the emotional attachment to
the plan yeah because I see these people
come up with plans and they would be so
addicted to their own plan only because
it was their own plan not for any not
for any tactical or strategic or
operational reason whatsoever just like
because they thought of it yeah that's
natural yeah it's very natural yeah and
there's some element of of benefit to
that right because if you're passionate
about your plan and I'm passion about my
plan as long as we can eventually come
to compromise then we've put forth the
best idea because I don't want you to
not be passionate about your plan while
you're planning it I wasn't really
coming up with the best plan that you
really believe it and and it's
interesting you know you talk about
poking holes right poking holes in the
plan and we all know that it's very easy
to sit back and poke holes man and what
I'm telling you to do as a leader is to
absolutely do that not be a jerk no no
and I'm talking as a leader if I if I
let you do the planning but it's easy
for me to sit back and poke holes in the
plan right which is good it's good
because we're gonna come up with we're
gonna fill those holes once I poke the
holes we're gonna fill them we're gonna
know that they're taken care of also as
a leader from a from a perspective point
you think aim chocolate really knows
what's going on he was able to find
these holes in the plan the real reason
I was able to find him is just cuz I was
not totally at-at miniscule detail when
you were I was up at altitude relaxing
looking around yeah it's gonna I don't
want to say cheating such cheating but
it is cheating is cheating it's that
much easier it's so much easier to sit
back and do it yeah and let things go
that way like when you know when you
watch a movie and you have like some
critique the movies outstanding and then
you have some critique ahead they
shouldn't chose that guy for that role
or whatever meanwhile the movies like
groundbreaking whatever you know so it's
easy to poke holes in the movie
meanwhile like yeah yeah when it's done
you're all like poking holes up the
little imperfections do that all the
time make sense I dig it does it happen
with your videos probably